Dans une précédente vidéo,
j’ai pu pénétrer et vous montrer
une des prisons kurdes en Syrie
où sont détenus
les djihadistes de l’État Islamique.
Comme vous pouvez le voir,
toutes les pièces sont bondées.
Il n’y a quasiment pas
de place pour se déplacer.
Là, il n’y a quasiment pas
de lumière du jour.
Et si aujourd’hui ces prisons
sont des bombes à retardement,
c’est notamment à cause
de l’invasion turque en octobre 2019.
La Turquie qui a envahi des territoires
jusque-là contrôlés par les Kurdes.
Les forces kurdes ont prévenu
dès le début de l’opération
que l’invasion turque pourrait se traduire
par une résurgence de l’État Islamique.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’elles ne pouvaient plus
concentrer leurs efforts
sur la lutte contre les cellules dormantes
de l’organisation terroriste
et parce qu’elles ne pourraient plus assurer
de la même manière
la sécurité des prisons et des camps
où sont détenus des milliers
de djihadistes de l’État Islamique.
L’offensive turque a posé plein de problèmes.
On a dû envoyer beaucoup de nos gardiens
sur la ligne de front.
La sécurité du front
est plus importante que celle de la prison.
Dans cette vidéo, je vais essayer
de vous expliquer pourquoi
des centaines de milliers de personnes
ont dû fuir leur ville et leur village
sous la pression de l’armée turque
et de leurs alliés syriens.
Je suis pour Brut au nord-est de la Syrie,
plus précisément
dans le gouvernorat d’Hassaké.
Derrière moi, c’est le camp de déplacés
de Washo Kani où se trouvent
principalement des Kurdes et des Arabes
qui ont fui les zones de combat,
envahies par l’armée turque et ses milices.
Donc là, dans cette tente,
c’est les nouveaux arrivants
du camp de Washo Kani et en fait,
ils attendent de pouvoir récupérer une tente.
Là, il y a une cinquantaine de personnes,
principalement des enfants en bas âge.
Et comme vous pouvez le voir derrière moi,
ils sont vraiment entassés les uns sur les autres.
En fait, la plupart des déplacés du camp
sont des enfants et des femmes.
Il y a plus de 4400 personnes.
Parmi elles, il y a environ 2000 femmes
et entre 1150 et 1200 enfants.
Là, ils sont en train de faire
une distribution de nourriture.
Ils leur donnent principalement des boîtes de conserve
pour ne pas qu’ils allument de feu,
pour ne pas qu’ils cuisinent dans la tente
parce que ça pourrait être très dangereux.
Et c’est principalement des boîtes de conserve
de haricots avec de la viande et aussi des chips.
Nous avons fui la guerre,
on a fui les bombardements.
On a tout laissé derrière
et on est partis les mains vides,
avec seulement nos vêtements sur le dos.
Vous êtes combien ?
Nous sommes neuf.
Sept enfants, mon épouse et moi.
Ici, mes enfants et moi
sommes en sécurité.
C'est le plus important.
Ici, c'est mieux.
Là-bas, la situation est mauvaise.
Pour bien comprendre
la situation de ces déplacés,
en fait, il faut remonter
quelques années en arrière.
Je vous préviens, c’est pas simple,
faut s’accrocher un peu.
À partir de 2014, c’est une alliance
entre les forces kurdes syriennes
et la coalition internationale contre l’État Islamique,
emmenée par les États-Unis,
qui a permis de chasser les djihadistes
du nord-est de la Syrie
et de reprendre leur capitale, Raqqa.
Après la défaite finale de l’État Islamique,
les forces kurdes attendaient
de leurs alliés occidentaux,
notamment américains, qu’ils se maintiennent
sur place et les protègent
contre leurs nombreux rivaux
et ennemis régionaux, notamment la Turquie.
Sauf qu’après la chute de Daech,
le président Donald Trump avait annoncé
à plusieurs reprises qu’il souhaitait
le retrait des troupes américaines en Syrie.
Et début Octobre 2019,
juste avant le début de l’invasion turque,
il a fait cette déclaration :
Nous voulons rapatrier nos troupes.
Cela fait des années,
voire des décennies dans bien des cas.
Nous voulons rapatrier nos troupes
et j'ai été élu pour cela.
La Turquie, la Syrie...
Laissons-les s'en occuper.
C’est après un coup de téléphone
entre Erdogan et Trump
que l’assurance a été donnée
au président turc
que les forces américaines allaient quitter
deux postes de la frontière syro-turque,
ce qui permettrait aux forces turques
et à leurs alliés d’entrer sur le territoire.
Il faut préciser aussi que
le président turc Recep Tayyip Erdogan
considère que les forces kurdes
en Syrie sont des terroristes
parce qu’elles ont des liens avec le PKK,
le parti des travailleurs du Kurdistan,
une organisation politique et militaire
considérée comme terroriste
par la communauté internationale et qui
a déjà revendiqué des attentats en Turquie.
Nous voulons faire savoir
que tout près de nos frontières,
des organisations terroristes reçoivent de l'aide,
reçoivent des armes
et des cellules terroristes
sont créées dans la région.
Cette montée en puissance
du mouvement kurde en Syrie,
soit à la frontière de la Turquie,
a commencé à beaucoup inquiéter Ankara
qui, dès lors, a fondé toute
sa politique syrienne sur l’objectif
d’affaiblir, voire de détruire,
le mouvement kurde en Syrie.
Le président turc justifie alors
cette opération militaire
par la création d’une zone tampon de 5 km de large
à la frontière turco-syrienne.
L’objectif de cette zone tampon était double,
d’abord chasser les forces kurdes
syriennes et ensuite installer
des centaines de milliers de réfugiés
syriens actuellement en Turquie.
Une des choses que j’ai le plus entendue
dans le camp, c’est le mot “trahison”.
Les Kurdes ont vraiment le sentiment
d’avoir été abandonnés par la coalition,
d’avoir été jetés en pâture
à l’armée turque et à ses milices
qui ont massacré et tué beaucoup de gens.
Il y a des vidéos qui circulent
sur les réseaux sociaux.
On est venu vous décapiter,
vous les infidèles, les apostats !
Si Dieu le veut,
on va venir s'occuper de vous !
Dans quelques heures,
on vous montrera les têtes décapitées.
Sur le terrain, ce n’était pas uniquement
des militaires turcs qui étaient engagés
mais aussi des miliciens syriens
qui sont issus de groupes armés islamistes
qui ont combattu le régime de Bachar el-Assad
depuis le début de la guerre civile syrienne.
Ce sont des prisonniers !
Allahu akbar !
Tuez-les !
Prends mon téléphone pour me filmer.
Filme-moi quand je lui tire dessus
avec le sniper.
Ces miliciens ont la réputation
d’avoir commis de nombreuses exactions :
des exécutions sommaires,
des enlèvements, des tortures
et ce sont ces miliciens qui ont pris le contrôle,
petit à petit, de villages,
chassant les populations locales
et notamment les populations kurdes.
Et justement dans le camp,
j’ai rencontré Amira et sa famille
qui ont été victimes de cette offensive militaire.
Elle a 5 enfants, dont le dernier
a seulement deux semaines,
et elle a été témoin des exactions
des milices pro-turques.
Ils tuent tous les enfants.
Ils n'ont pas de pitié pour les enfants
et les personnes agées.
Ils n'ont de pitié pour personne.
On a vraiment peur,
on ne retournera pas là-bas.
Tant qu'ils y seront,
on ne rentrera pas.
On restera ici.
Et ces histoires de massacres, tous les déplacés
que j’ai rencontrés là-bas m’en ont parlé
et c’est en partie ces traumatismes
qui expliquent le sentiment d’abandon
qu’ont les Kurdes aujourd’hui.
Les forces kurdes syriennes et leurs alliés
ont perdu plus de 10 000 hommes et femmes
dans les combats contre l’État Islamique.
Le retrait des forces américaines
de la frontière syro-turque en octobre 2019
a donc été considéré par les Kurdes, qui estiment
avoir mené la guerre contre l’État Islamique
pour le compte de la coalition internationale,
comme une trahison.
Ils ne nous ont pas aidés.
Ils nous ont juste aidés à combattre Daech.
Après les avoir vaincus,
ils nous ont laissés seuls.
Il faut qu’ils se mettent à notre place.
Pourquoi nous ont-ils abandonnés ?
On est des êtres humains comme eux.
On veut vivre,
on veut juste vivre.
Mais ils nous ont abandonnés.
Pas seulement eux mais aussi
tous les autres pays.
Qu’est-ce qu’on a fait pour vivre
dans une telle misère ?
Qu’ont fait nos enfants pour vivre
dans cette douleur et ce froid ?
On espère recevoir de l'aide…
J’aimerais retourner dans ma ville
et y vivre en paix.
Ça suffit, la guerre.
On veut que la guerre
contre le Rojava syrien s’arrête.
Pour que notre peuple kurde
puisse vivre en paix.